donc ces tablettes venait de les avoir
aussi pour la rentrée c'est la nouveauté
de la rentrée pour ces élèves en
situation de handicap du collège henri
iv de meulan en yvelines des tablettes
numériques
un nouvel outil prévu par le plan
numérique du département
au total 23 tablettes ont été livrés à
cet établissement et vous êtes contents
de retrouver ça dans l'établissement
lorsqu'on vous parle d'henri iv que
à voir quelques extraits de téléfilm sur
henri iv qui passe par la tablette
numérique
c'est vrai que ça rend le court plus
vivant ça permet de mieux capter
l'attention des élèves en plus du
numérique le département s'engage dans
des travaux de rénovation et dans la
sécurité des collèges pour 2017 le
budget éducation s'élève à près de 140
millions d'euros en hausse de 10% par
rapport à 2016 des réflexions sont
engagées sur la politique tarifaire de
la restauration et sur des internats
d'excellence comme celui de marly le roi
objectif de ce type d'établissements
scolaires réduire la fracture
territoriale et donc permettre à des
enfants de jeunes adolescents de quitter
des quartiers défavorisés le temps de
leurs études en semaine pour être plus
au calme et plus dans leur recherche
d'excellence
autre expérimentation dans tout ce
collège de six communes du département
notamment à trappes des chargés de
mission pour faire de la prévention
auprès d'élèves en difficulté